what is a tractor PTO we're going to
tell you all about it today as always
we're sponsored by Bora wheel spacers
they are made in America have a lifetime
warranty if your tractor feels Tippy
side to side especially if you have a
cab on it then adding a set of wheel
spacers can make a big difference get
more information on them at the link
down below all right so this button
right here yellow button sometimes is
something you push but in this situation
here you're going to pull on it that is
your PTO knob it's going to engage and
turn on the PTO if your tractor is on so
let's define a PTO what that stands for
is a power
takeoff I can see where they're going
with it so basically what that means is
you're going to have a an output shaft
either underneath here on a mid PTO or a
rear PTO a set of splines and so when
you tie in a PTO shaft on an attachment
to it it's then going to provide Power
so it's taking off power uh from the
main shaft here and so I think maybe
that's why they call it a power takeoff
but I didn't come up with it so we're
going to roll with it all right so
diving a little deeper into how a PTO
works and what it's all about you can
compare it to a Bel drive system or to a
hydraulic motor there's other ways to
power attachments that might be on a
piece of equipment many simplistic or
more basic lawn mowers for example are
going to have belt drive mowers on there
so that's a different way to power an
attachment like a lawn mower and that's
typically going to be a cheaper way to
go about it now on the flip side one of
the more expensive ways to power an
attachment is going to be like what you
see on my skid steer if I want to drive
a multure head or a brush hog on my skid
steer that's all going to be using
hydraulic power hydraulic pumps and
motors and those are very expensive
going to really raise the cost off
typically you see that on more like
construction equipment not really on
tractors and not on lawn mes either so
you have different options with belt
driven PTO driven and hydraulic motor
driven the commonality is that with any
of those systems you need an engine to
initiate that power all right and so
that's where in the PTO system it's all
coming from Power generated off of the
engine it starts here it works its way
back through an output shaft in a way
similar to the PTO shaft that drives the
back to the transaxle all right now in
simplistic terms there's just a lot of
gearing in here to get to the right
ratios the right speeds and then that
ties into a small output shaft for the
mid PTO and then also a larger output
shaft for the rear PTO now I'm not a
super technical guy so we're not going
to get into all the details but it is a
Marvel of engineering if you think about
it because the output shaft for the PTO
on the backside so your rear PTO is
going to be a standardized 540 RPMs for
all of you subcompact and compact
tractor owners now for your mid PTO it's
typically going to be around 2100 RPMs
that will vary a little bit from
manufacturer to manufacturer like a
johnar versus Kabota versus Mahindra
that kind of thing but the thing with
mid PTO is that typically those are
going to be for your belly mowers all
right and so belly mowers are very
specific to a tractor brand and a
tractor model you can't just go buy a
generic belly mower and slap it on any
old tractor that's going to be specific
from the manufacturer whereas on a
three-point hitch there's a slew just a
whole world of attachment Brands and
manufacturers and companies out there
that you can get and since the
three-point hitch and the PTO are all
standardized back here you have a lot of
options now sometimes I don't want to
confuse you too much but you are going
to hear the term front PTO so we have
rear PTO the 540 we talked about mid PTO
the 2100 RPM give or take that we talked
about and then this front PTO now I know
there's always exceptions to the rule
but I can't think of any right now and
typically when you have a front PTO it's
actually a kit that runs off of the mid
PTO all right and a really good example
for this is if you get a front mounted
snowblower so you can get a 47 or a 54in
front mount blower for the John Deere
1025r So when you buy that kit from your
dealer and again just like that belly
mower the front blowers are typically
very specific to the model of tractor uh
to the brand of tractor that kind of
thing you can't grab a a front mounted
snowblower from cabota and put it on a
John Deere without having some major
fabrication skills so when you get that
blower you get a whole kit for it all
right you get a Qui kits you get these
other brackets that mount on there uh
reverse override sensors some other
little adapters and things like that and
then the important thing is you get a
long PTO shaft that's going to mount
into a carrier bearing up here but
connect back to the same spot that your
mid-mount mower your belly mower would
connect to so you're technically running
it off of the mid PTO and driving your
front snowblower so from what I know
about PTO shafts is that when tractors
were really designed to be used on farms
you know Farmers aren't the the rich
folk in the world right so they wanted
to have a good reliable solution that
was pretty well foolproof robust easy to
use just didn't break down right so I
think those reasons are why you still
see PTO shafts on tractors today because
they're just they're simple to use
they're really reliable they're really
strong you seldom have an issue with it
if you do it's relegated to a couple of
specific models that maybe were known to
be problematic or it could be something
like a selenoid issue which is going to
be one of the more common problems with
the PTO if you have a selenoid that's
not clicking and and working and
functioning like it should to activate
or turn it off that kind of thing but
seldom seldom are you going to have an
issue with the PTO itself hey now I know
a lot of you are going to struggle with
connecting to your PTO shaft on your
tractor so we made a whole video All
About tips to help make that process
easier I'd encourage you to check it out
there's also going to be a product you
can get to make that connection process
easier you're staring at it right here
it's the PTO link by tractor PTO
link.com you go to their website to buy
it use code GWT to save 5% off of your
order but this is going to move that
connection point out further to a more
accessible location on your tractor
going to take a lot of pain out of the
process this is a maiden America company
all right so a high quality this is all
machined all around here very high
quality solution you can save some money
again with code GWT so really one of the
big things that sets this system apart
from the others that are out there is it
doesn't require any tools to install it
all right so John Deere has a system
where you actually have to take off you
have to take apart the ujin on your your
attachments and replace it with this
system there's another system out there
that does require tools to install this
is really easy guys it really is you
just line this side up with your PTO
splines you pop it
on just like a regular attachment and
then it's there in place good to go that
was one-handed by the way if you didn't
notice this one here same thing on your
attachment you just hold it up twist it
in there pull the collar back on your
attachment I am using two hands but
that's it all right pop it in there and
you're good to go so for ease of
illustration I'm holding it here showing
you but this is the tractor side that's
going to be on there this is the
attachment side all right so your normal
PTO splines you have six different
splines that you have to line up with
very little play in between there it's
got to be exactly right so you're taking
it down to only four points to line up
so it just makes a little easier and
they're going to have a little bit more
play in it so you just have to line them
up just somewhat just kind of match it
up they're going to have some play they
lock into place and you can see this is
just a spring loaded pin all right so
that pops into place as well helps lock
it there and then they do include one
extra retainer pin that this is going to
be the attachment side all right you'll
just pop it through I think right here
yep get that through you're locked in
place you're good to go again visit
tractor PTO link.com save 5% with code
GWT all right so that gives you a pretty
good General understanding of what a PTO
is all about but there's still a few
critical things to know to make sure
that you're using it the right way so
the first thing to know is what your PTI
horsepower is all right and so you
generally think of your engine
horsepower whether that's your car your
boat your tractor you're thinking of
just the engine horsepower but as you
take the power from the engine and drive
it all the way through the system out to
the output shafts on the PTO whether
it's the the rear or the mid you're
losing some power it's not 100%
efficiency for example just nominal
numbers you have 25 horsepower at the
engine on this tractor but the PTO
horsepower at the output there is going
to be 18 so you're losing 7 horsepower
25 to 18 and on smaller tractors it's a
smaller difference right but if you go
to a 60 horsepower or a 70 horsepower
tractor or something larger well on a 60
horsepower you may only have 48 you know
or 50 horsepower at the PTO so you're
going to lose 10 or 12 horsepower that
way and not to muddy the waters too much
but there is going to be a difference
between hydrostatic machines and Gear
Drive machines you're going to lose more
horsepower with a hydro machine because
part of that power is going to the
hydrostatic system whereas a Gear Drive
is just a more simplistic drive system
all around and so your losses at the
rear PTO aren't as significant right
here you have a PTO driven snowblower on
the back of our tractor so that PTO
shaft is driving the augur that as
you're moving forward this is a pull
type snowblower so as you move forward
this augur spins around because it's
being powered by the PTO shaft it
collects that snow and drives it up
through the shoe and and shoots it out
so you need to be able to size your
attachment to the amount of PTO
horsepower that you have all right so
other things come into play as well you
have to have a three-point hitch system
that is strong enough to lift up the
attachment as well but any good
manufacturer is going to have that
information available all right so
they're going to offer this snowblower
and 54 you know 60 incremental segments
all the way up to probably 7 8T wide
okay and so all those different sizes of
attachments are going to have a
different range of PTO horsepower that
they can work with all right so maybe
it's 18 horsepower up to 30 horsepower
and for a bigger one maybe it's 40
horsepower minimum up to 100 horsepower
maximum so for that range or sometimes
you may only see a minimum or only a
maximum if the gearbox is not going to
be affected by anything else but many
attachments like a brush hog for example
are going to have a gearbox on them and
we just talked about the dirt dog uh
brush Hogs recently and they have a 60
horsepower rated gearbox so that means
at the PTO they're rated to be used on a
machine with up to 60 horsepower coming
out of there all right now to get you in
the right ballpark take a look at this
setup here so it's typically not always
but typically going to work out that a P
driven three-point attachment is going
to match up with the width or be really
darn close to the width of your tractor
and that's the case here our tractor is
uh 48 in wide we have a 54in wide
snowblower so it hangs out 3 in wider on
either side and this is a great fit for
this machine so if you are completely
lost with what size attachment to get
measure the width of your tractor and
then find an attachment that's roughly
the same size and then at that point you
can kind of drill down deeper if you
need to look at the PTO ratings see if
it's going to match up with what you
need or if you need to go a size down or
a size larger all right and while I've
got your attention just a few quick tips
and pointers so pay attention if you
don't know much about PTO shafts but
there's a lot of parts of the system
that are actually there to protect you
okay but number one is often times
depending on your tractor if you hop off
the tractor seat with the PTO engag it's
going to kill the tractor and that's a
safety mechanism so that you're not
driving a belly mower you know all
across the lawn into the house into
Landscaping into whatever else it is
that it's not supposed to be so that's
safety item number one now right in this
area there's three more safety features
as well number one on the tractor you're
going to have this shroud that goes up
and down you can lift it up to help make
it easier to connect to your attachment
and then you're going to have this
plastic cover that goes over top it's
free floating like this all right
because this is not or you don't want it
to spin with the actual steel shaft
that's inside of it there so and to help
prevent that from spinning at a certain
point you can see these chains all right
so these chains are meant to hold the
shaft in place at a certain point it
won't spin any further once it gets
there and so this one we actually broke
off um sometime recently I don't know
when exactly but that's part of the
downside of these chains is they are
kind of flimsy and they will break and
so often times you're going to see it
like this where this is free spinning so
the thing is you don't ever want to get
tangled up down here in fact there's
this nasty looking picture uh of this
guy completely wrapped around his PTO
shaft all right so uh that's the idea
Safety First we've done a lot of videos
on on tractor safety PTO safety so make
sure you check those out and watch them
too all right so PTO shafts are going to
be a two-part unit so you have an inner
and an outer uh section that slide over
top of one another and it's going to be
at its shortest point when it's
perfectly level all right so anytime
it's moving up above that or down below
that it needs to lengthen out and if it
was one piece well you'd be ripping
something apart and so that's why you
have to have it slide over top of one
another and you don't want to cut the
shaft too long or Too Short if it's too
short you potentially risk that shaft
completely coming apart and if it's too
long once you get to your shortest setup
so as you go from a little bit longer
like it's sitting on the ground right
now as you raise that up it's going to
get a little bit shorter and if you had
it cut too long it could potentially
bind up and if it's operating really
wreak havoc and if it's even if it's off
it can still bend that PTO shaft a
little bit so there's a sweet spot
reference the manual that comes with
whatever attachment is that you get
there's a lot of information online
these things are easy to cut down to you
can cut it down with a hacksaw or a saww
very easy to do just follow those
instructions and you'll be good to go
well that's going to wrap it up for us
today hopefully that gives you a better
understanding of what appear is all
about on your tractor if you did enjoy
today's video we'd love to have you tag
along hit that subscribe button right
down below to see more and if you're
looking for something for your tractor
for the front-end loader or the
three-point hitch we sell and ship
attachments all across the country every
day of the week check out
goodworkstractors decom I want to thank
you for taking time out of your day to
stop by and until next time stay safe
we'll see you soon
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]